una molécula de agua tiene dos átomos de
hidrógeno y uno de oxígeno colocados de
forma similar a la que se muestra en la
figura esta de acá si la molécula se
dibuja en los ejes coordenadas como se
muestra corte a continuación
cuál es la relación entre los dos átomos
de hidrógeno bueno pues vamos a ver cómo
de qué tipo son las respuestas son como
de reflexiones ok entonces si nos
fijamos aquí tenemos un átomo de
hidrógeno y acá tenemos otro básicamente
es como si el eje y actuara como un
espejo eso quiere decir que estamos
reflejando uno de los átomos de
hidrógeno con respecto al eje y para
obtener el otro entonces sería uno es el
reflejo del otro a través del eje y muy
bien vamos a hacer otros otros de estos
ejercicios dice el punto b es una
reflexión del punto a a través de qué
eje bueno aquí está el punto b aquí está
el punto a entonces me parece que
tenemos que reflejar con respecto a
ambos ejes qué sucede si reflejamos
primero con respecto al eje y bueno es
como si el eje y actuara comunes
y entonces el punto a quedaría más o
menos por acá y aquí a estas seis
unidades a la izquierda en el -6 la
reflexión va a quedar seis unidades a la
derecha aquí con x igual a 6 justo en
este en este punto de acá pero eso
todavía no es la reflexión o eso más
bien todavía no es ve entonces todavía
hay que reflejar con respecto al eje x
verdad si ahora pensamos al eje x como
un lago entonces aquí fuimos cinco
unidades hacia arriba el punto de estas
cinco unidades hacia abajo de modo que
este punto que obtuvimos reflejando aa
con respecto al eje y al reflejarlo con
respecto al eje x cayenne b vaya eso
simplemente quiere decir que ve es la
reflexión de a pero reflejando con
respecto a ambos ejes vale entonces la
respuesta sería el eje x y luego el eje
que vamos a hacer uno más nos dice las
moléculas de dióxido de carbono
consisten de dos átomos de oxígeno y un
átomo de carbono todos en una línea con
el carbón en medio
así si dibujamos la molécula sobre los
ejes coordinados que secuencia de
transformación
movería un oxígeno al otro bueno pues es
la misma idea que en el primero verdad
aquí el oxígeno está tres unidades a la
izquierda este tres unidades a la
derecha entonces es una reflexión con
respecto al eje y muy bien